Robert George,
he's the moral professor of the professor of moral philosophy over at Princeton.
He says he uses this as this sort of thought experiment. He says, okay,
so he'll ask his class, you're living in 1860 in Alabama.
Are you an abolitionist or are you pro slavery?
And everybody in the room that everyone says, I'm an abolitionist.
And then he's like, really,
really are you because I'd love for you to name these extremely unpopular
position you're taking at the risk to your life,
reputation and career right now today.
Like it actually risks anything because none of you can name any of them, right?
You're, you're actually going along to get along with most of your morality.
The example that I like to use on this is w we're living in an era where
everybody thinks of themselves as,
as deeply enlightened and all of this 100 years from now, all these,
all the statues of president Obama will come down. Why?
Because he ate meat a hundred years from now.
All the statutes of president Obama will come down because there's video of him
at campaign rallies in Iowa, campaign stops eating a corn dog.
Pause there for a second because we're dealing with this cancel culture nonsense
right now. Do you think that there is just a certain inertia to movements,
like cancel culture? Because of, because of all of the stuff that we started,
this conversation talking about that it's like,
we've had this thing slowly building,
but now it does feel like it hit the tipping point and now it's just spread
everywhere. Do you think there's like a functional reason?
Yeah. I mean,
I think that there've been decades of an attempt to rethink what rights actually
mean. So one of the things that,
that the left has done is in the same way that we started off by talking about
the redefinition of racism,
they've redefined nearly every term that we've talked about here,
they've redefined every element of American philosophy to mean almost the
precise reverse of what originally was meant to me.
They've redefined virtually all of American history, which is what the 16,
19 project is about. And they've redefined our culture of rights.
So that rights are in fact ways to oppress people, right?
This is when we talked a little bit earlier about the rights of free speech
being seen as a way for the powerful to silence the powerless.
And you see people actually saying this kind of stuff. Yeah.
I mean,
this is in effect what Ray white fragility is about in effect what all of the,
the whole BLM platform, this is what it is about.
Like you're not just making this.
No, I mean, I, and when I wrote the book,
I didn't realize that it was gonna break into the open this way.
I really thought that honestly, when COVID hit in March, I thought, okay,
I wrote this book to rush out before the election,
and now it's gonna be irrelevant because it's all going to be COVID all of his
time. And then all this stuff just broke loose in the last couple of months.
And I thought, wow. I mean, I'm not a prophet, but if I were that,
that's really how it feels. I mean,
looking back through the book and realizing that all the arguments that I was
making against this particular vision of America,
which I called this integrationist,
and the reason I call it this integrationist is because I think that it really
stands for the coming apart of America.
I think that there's a group of people who say,
here are all the things we have in common. And as Lincoln said,
we have to be brothers because if we're not brothers, we're going to be enemies,
right? That's, that's just how this is going to be.
The better angels of our nature had better when,
and we better all be on the same page or we're going to fall apart.
I think there's a group of people who believe that they are the sole exposers of
ultimate truth. And as the sole expositors of ultimate truth,
they get to club everybody else into submission.
And therefore all of the checks and balances should go away because they are now
the godlike leaders who know all the wisdom of the ages.
They're the best people who have ever.
It's incredible that they're unbelievable are better than everyone that came.
Lucky people we are to be living in this time,
this time with such unbelievably special people, right?
We get to rip down statues of Ulysses S grant and who get to suggest that
Abraham Lincoln was a bad man. Whereas they, they would,
if they'd been living in 1863, they wouldn't have just been abolitionists.
They would have been people who are arguing for, for all and to segregation and,
and, and complete mixing of people of different races. Like they,
all the principles they hold today that are good principles, right?
All those principals,
they would have held them doubtless in 1863 with no background in any of this
stuff. If they'd been born,
all of their values are sort of floating me as magically in the atmosphere and
they internalize them and they would have been, if it wouldn't matter,
you could have plopped them down in Rome in, in 100 BC.
And they would have held exactly the same values they exist outside of time.
They exist outside of history.
They exist absent to any other outside influences.
They're just the most incredible people who have ever lived in the history of
humanity. Good for them.
And good for us that we get to live at a time of such saints.
It's so interesting because I've been thinking about this a lot.
Like if you think about how fast it seems, the world is moving right now, like,
just think about today, versus just what we were talking about.
Say 10 years ago in 2010, whatever the hell it was. Now,
if you take that further back and you pop that person down in 1863,
and try to imagine how different the world is like people don't really just sit
in that for a minute and realize how different it was without plumbing and
electricity and all of those things. And yet,
somehow their entire moral code would have been you to which they make up.
[inaudible].
They're not standing on the shoulders of giants.
They didn't learn anything from Lincoln.
American history has nothing to do with their positions.
They exist as free floating moral actors in the universe without any background
whatsoever. They came to all of the exact right conclusions about life.
Simply through APR. I thinking it's, it's,
it's truly an unbelievable achievement of the human mind. I think again,
we should, we should all feel very lucky to be in their presence. Look,
of course, this is all. I mean,
the fact is Robert George is the moral professor of professor of moral
philosophy over at Princeton. He says,
he uses this as this sort of thought experiment. He says, okay,
so in Alaska's class, you're living in 1860 in Alabama, are you an abolitionist?
Or are you pro slavery? And everybody in the room that everyone says,
I'm an abolitionist. And then he's like, really,
really are you because I love for you to name these extremely unpopular position
you're taking at the risk to your life, reputation and career right now today.
Like it actually risks anything because none of you can name any of them, right?
You're, you're actually going along to get along with most of your morality.
The example that I like to use on this is we're living in an era where everybody
thinks of themselves as,
as deeply enlightened and all of this a hundred years from now, all these,
all the statutes of president Obama will come down. Why?
Because he ain't made a a hundred years from now.
All the statutes of president Obama will come down because there's video of him
at campaign rallies, you know, in Iowa campaign stops eating a corn dog.
He had that hot dog, right. And people are going to say, w w.
I'm with you on this? It's the next frontier of this lunacy.
And what's going to happen is it's going to be,
there were people who back then that this was being mean to animals and you
ignored that sort of, that sort of suffering. It means animals.
It's also destroying the environment, right. It's just right, right. Yeah.
You drove a car, right? I mean, there were people who aren't driving cars.
You can't say that you were completely innocent in all of us,
but nobody's completely innocent in all of this.
The reason that we erect monuments to people's for the good stuff,
they did not the bad stuff they did. Um, but again,
when you think of yourself as better than any human being who has ever lived,
it gives you an awful lot of moral authority to rip down everything around you.
So we've, we've sort of veered into chapter two here, which is,
when you talk about that disintegration,
do you think that once something starts disintegrating at a certain rate,
that then it's inevitable that it will disintegrate because,
and that's sort of what we're.
I think a lot of people are feeling that right now, like, Oh my God,
the world really has shifted. The conversation has shifted.
It feels like everything's out of control. Can it actually, you know,
if the wave has started, can you actually turn the way?
I mean, I think the only way to really turn the wave around is to refamiliarize
ourselves with principals, which is a difficult task. I mean, we've,
we've basically assumed that freedom was in the water for 50 years,
60 years. And it turns out freedom was not in the water.
Kool-Aid was in the water and people have been drinking at a university campuses
and they've been reading Howard's in for awhile.
And now they think they have a very sophisticated view of the world. And,
and so it takes some,
some education in American history and American philosophy to really rethink
locate that. But that's a hard, that's a hard slog.
I think it's gonna be a rough time here. I don't think this is gonna,
I think there's this assumption on the part of liberals,
like good-hearted liberals who actually believe a lot of the stuff in the book,
cause this is not partisan right now.
I really believe that everything that I've said about American history and
American culture, like rights are good. And the declaration of independence,
all human beings are equal before the law.
Like this should be pretty consensus stuff. I mean,
this is not right left or center. I know a lot of liberals who agree with us,
but I think that there's this assumption that because everything is Trump
polarized, that if Biden is elected, that all this sort of goes back to normal,
everybody calms down, it goes away.
I think they are really underestimating and descendant left that sees the,
that sees the wave of history behind them.
And they also see a weak actor in JobBite and they feel like they can push them
around. And I think they're probably right about that.
I mean, the guy has got serious problems. It's like, that's the scandal, right?
Like, isn't that the scandal that no one will talk about the scandal,
which is that obviously something's wrong with them.
I mean, it's,
it is pretty incredible that that's considered such an out of balance opinion.
I mean, the boy held it without any evidence.
You're suggesting that he's on the verge of senility. I mean,
I don't watch a tape of him like eight years ago and then watch a tape of him
today. And Joe Biden was never any great shakes,
but he looks like a different dude. I mean, and listen,
you can elect them if you want. I mean, that's, that's your prerogative,
but recognize that there's a high likelihood,
you're also electing as vice-president.
Right. So, okay. So we,
we started talking about culture and I wanted to pause you in the middle of it
because when we talk about culture and someone's going to say,
you're talking about American culture, that's chapter three,
but American culture must mean white culture.
That's what you really mean Shapiro is that it's about white.
Culture, right? And this, this goes back to this whole anti-racist idea,
which is that rights themselves are a vestige of white supremacist system,
which ignores all of the progress. Not only made by black people,
but made by black people in the name of rights, in the name of rights,
Martin Luther King saying we ought to have the same freedoms that you all are
guaranteed. W our freedom of speech matters no less than your freedom of speech,
an American saying, because you're making that argument, not the argument,
the entire system is bad,
not the sort of early Malcolm that's argument that white people are devils.
And the entire system is garbage and all of this,
this stuff that he abandoned later in his career, you know,
because you're making the actual American argument. Yeah. We'll give that.
We'll give that a hearing that makes it, that makes sense to us, right? I mean,
this was the argument, again, being made by Frederick Douglas.
He wasn't saying that July 4th is bad.
He's saying we're not included in that promise.
We should be included in that promise.
When you invoke the deep principles of America, you are like, your,
your movement is likely to see victory, right?
This is the same thing that happened with, with the gay rights movement.
The gay rights movement said, listen,
you guys are guaranteed freedom of association,
you're guaranteed freedom and who you love. Right? So it was a rights argument.
Now I may not have agreed with the application with regard to behavior, but the,
the actual rights are with regard to marriage with the actual early argument,
which was, everybody should basically be left alone.
That was a very robust argument.
It had a lot of power behind it because most Americans went. Yeah,
that makes sense to me. I mean, I have that kind of freedom. Why that,
why shouldn't that guy have that kind of freedom? Like why not? Right.
Which is a different argument than some of the arguments we're now having,
which had moved beyond the rubric of rights into, well,
I can demand from you a good or service. I can write that.
That's a bit of a different thing.
We're looking for more honest and thoughtful conversations about politics
instead of nonstop yelling, checkout our politics playlist.
And if you want to watch full interviews on a variety of topics,
watch our full episode playlists, all right, over here,
and to get notified of all future videos,
be sure to subscribe and click the notification bell.